I got my head I have to come in Monica's
I knew outlet on life it's like I'm
gonna live life to the fullest I'm gonna
make up my own body cuz ain't nothing a
party about but I'm a party because the
Devils alive was everything a party
about because you know that don't stroke
she had you never know so I think it's
good for the party but do you think it's
fair for her to have to party in LA fair
yes dude why tell me why you use the
word fan I used to work fair because I
think her life is more fulfilled in
Georgia Tamar doesn't want to hear what
anybody has to say with any regard to
mommy all she knows is she wants mommy
there she was want me to stay with her
and whenever anyone else has anything to
say she starts acting like a brat but
mommy's one who made this decision we
didn't make the decision for mommy
so Tamar you you can respect mommy's
wishes and not try and find any reason
to get mommy to come back and forth to
LA let me tell you why [ __ ] but wait
wait wait you didn't you let me finish
because she has her own space she has
her own car she has her own friends
email me laughs away I think mommy
should be in LA I think for the time
being because it's just at the stroke
she should be here I just think that she
could get better care I know she'll do
great in Atlanta but I think she should
be here at least for six months Tamara
but you work all day no I don't work
really only yesterday a week and guess
what someone is always here with her she
said once I was in LA
she's not far as a pedestrian she is
always well let me take some the big
guys aren't a toddler no she's not but
she she's an older woman who don't need
to be by herself right now and she oh
she dresses in with wait a minute wait a
minute okay huh I look like I'm already
you can't walk away Oh